♪ TUCK WELL COMPARED TO THE
RAIDS IN THE 80'S AND EARLY
90'S, CRIME OVERALL IS DOWN
IN THIS COUNTRY.
RAMPAGE SHOOTERS ARE
INCREASINGLY COMMON AND
KILLING MORE PEOPLE
OBVIOUSLY.
ALMOST ALL OF THEM ARE YOUNG
MEN.
THE QUESTION WHICH FOR SOME
REASON VERY FEW PEOPLE ASK
BUT IS THE KEY QUESTION IS
WHAT'S DRIVING THIS SURGE IN
EXTREME ANTISOCIAL VIOLENCE
IN ONE MAN WHO HAS BEEN
THINKING ABOUT IT A LOT IS
JORDAN PETERSON.
A PSYCHOLOGY PROFESSOR AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF TORONTO.
HE JUST SPOKE WITH US
MOMENTS AGO.
HERE IT IS.
JORDAN PETERSON THANKS FOR
JOINING US TONIGHT.
>> MY PLEASURE.
>> Tucker: WE WANT TO ASK
THE QUESTION WHICH TOO FEW
ARE ASKING.
WHY IS THIS HAPPENING?
WHY ARE OUTCOME MEN SHOOTING
UP SCHOOLS?
>> BECAUSE THEY ARE
ANILISTIC AND DESPERATE.
>> Tucker: HOW DID THEY GET
THAT WAY?
>> WELL, I THINK LIFE CAN
MAKE YOU THAT WAY UNLESS YOU
HAVE A PURPOSE AND A
DESTINY, LET'S SAY THERE IS
NO SHORTAGE OF SUFFERING AND
MEN NOVEMBER LENS IN LIFE.
PETA PEOPLE BECOME
INBITTERRED BY THAT.
IN THIS F. THEY DON'T SEE A
WAY OUT AND FORWARD THEY GET
ANGRY AND TURN AGAINST LIFE
ITSELF.
THEY MAKE A DISPLAY OF THEIR
HATRED FOR BEING BY
MASSACRING THE INNOCENT.
THAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING.
AND IF THEY WRITE THAT.
>> Tucker: THEY DO WRITE
THAT.
IT'S ACCELERATING.
WE HAVE HAD SEMIAUTOMATIC
RIFLE AREstS FOR A NUMBER
OF YEARS.
WE HAVEN'T HAD THIS NUMBER
OF SCHOOL SHOOTINGS.
THE ATTITUDES ARE CHANGING.
WHY A MORE.
>> IT'S ALSO KIND OF A
PSYCHOLOGICAL EPIDEMIC, YOU
KNOW, THESE PEOPLE KEEP
TRACK OF EACH OTHER AND
THERE IS A COMPETITIVE
ELEMENT TO IT THE FACT THAT
THE MEDIA INSISTS UPON
PUBLICIZING THE NAMES OF
THESE SHOOTERS IS NOT
HELPFUL.
PART OF WHAT DRIVES THEM IS
MOTIVATION FOR NOTORIETY.
BECAUSE NOTORIETY IS BETTER
THAN BEING IGNORED.
>> Tucker: WHAT MISTAKES DO
YOU THINK WE ARE MAKING AS A
SOCIETY TO PRODUCE AN EVER
INCREASING NUMBER OF YOUNG
MEN LIKE THIS?
>> THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION.
I THINK WE UNDER ESTIMATE
THE NECESSITY FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE TO HAVE CLEAR
DIRECTION AND A SENSE OF
PURPOSE IN THEIR LIFE NEED
SOMETHING TO OFFSET THE
TRAGEDY AND MEN NOVEMBER
LENS OF LIFE.
WE NEED TO TAKE THESE SORTS
OF PHILOSOPHICAL AND
RELIGIOUS ISSUES SERIOUSLY
BUT WE DON'T.
>> Tucker: DO YOU THINK WE
ARE TAKING THEM LESS
SERIOUSLY THAN WE USED TO?
>> YES.
DEFINITELY.
I THINK WE TALK IN THE PAST
WE SPOKE MUCH MORE ABOUT
RESPONSIBILITY AND
RESPONSIBILITY IN
PARTICULAR.
BUT ALSO PURPOSE AND
MATURITY AND WE VALUED THOSE
THINGS HIGHLY.
WE DIDN'T CONFUSE THEM WITH
TYRANNY AND TOXIC
MASCULINITY, FOR EXAMPLE.
>> Tucker: WHY IS IT ALL
BOYS?
>> BOYS ARE MORE AGGRESSIVE
THAN GIRLS AND THERE IS A
BIOLOGICAL COMPONENT TO THAT
THAT IS QUITE STRONG.
THAT'S WHY THE VAST MAJORITY
OF PEOPLE IN PRISON ARE
MALE.
LIKE ON AVERAGE THERE IS NOT
MUCH DIFFERENCE IN
AGGRESSION BETWEEN MEN AND
WOMEN.
IF YOU PICKED A RANDOM WOMAN
AND A RANDOM MAN OUT OF THE
POPULATION AND HAD TO BET
WHO WAS THE MOST AGGRESSIVE.
IF YOU BET IT WAS THE WOMAN
YOU WOULD BE RIGHT 40% OF
THE TIME.
IF YOU TAKE THE ONE IN 100
MOST AGGRESSIVE PEOPLE AND
THOSE WOULD BE THE PEOPLE IN
PRISON THEY ARE ALL MEN OR
VIRTUALLY ALL MEN.
ALSO WHILE MALES ATTEMPT
SUICIDE LESS FREQUENTLY BUT
THEY COMPLETE IT
SUCCESSFULLY MUCH MORE
LIKELY TO USE LETHAL MEANS.
BIOLOGICAL COMPONENT TO THAT
DESPITE WHAT THE POST MODERN
SOCIAL CONSTRUCTIONISTS HAVE
TO SAY ABOUT IT THEY HAVE
THEIR HEAD FIRMLY BURIED IN
THE SAND.
>> Tucker: THEY'RE RESISTANT
TO THE EVIDENCE AND REALITY.
WE KNOW THAT GIVEN THAT WE
KNOW THAT BOYS ARE THE ONE
IF THERE IS A SCHOOL
SHOOTING GOING TO BE
COMMITTING IT
OVERWHELMINGLY.
SHOULDN'T WOULD HE BE
THINKING ABOUT HOW TO RAISE
OUR BOYS IN A WAY THAT THEY
ARE LESS LIKELY TO DO THIS?
>> YEAH.
I THINK WE SHOULD BE
THINKING ABOUT THAT THE BOOK
I PUBLISHED 12 RULES FOR
LIFE IS MEDITATION ON
EXACTLY THAT I HAVE BEEN
LECTURING ONLINE ABOUT THE
IDEA THAT RESPONSIBILITY IS
WHAT GIVES LIFE MEANING AND
THAT THAT MEANING IS THE
ANTIDOTE FOR THE ANIHILISM
AND AGGRESSION AND
RESENTMENT THAT CAN
OTHERWISE BE PRODUCED.
THERE IS NO LIFE IS
DIFFICULT AND GET HURT AND
BETRAYED, THAT'S
UNASSAILABLE TRUTH.
YOU NEED SOMETHING TO OFFSET
THAT AND MOST PEOPLE FIND
THAT IN THEIR ADOPTION OF
RESPONSIBILITY AND MAKE
THEIR OWN LIVES BETTER AND
MAKE THEIR OWN LIVES BETTER
AND CONTRIBUTE TO THE
COMMUNITY AND TO BEAR THE
BURDEN OF BEING NOBLABLY.
AND THAT WORKS WHY DON'T
THINK THAT WAY ANYMORE.
>> Tucker: YOU MENTION TOXIC
MASCULINITY.
I'M NOT SURE WHAT THAT MEANS
BUT I HAVE HEARD THE PHRASE
A LOT.
>> Tucker: WHAT DOES IT MEAN
IN PUBLIC CONVERSATION WHEN
SOMEONE ATTRIBUTES THE
SHOOTING TO TOXIC
MASCULINITY?
>> AN ATTEMPT TO SMEAR THE
IDEA OF MASCULINITY BY
CONFUSING MASCULINE
CONFIDENCE WITH TYRANNY.
IT'S PART OF THE UNDERLYING
IDEA THAT OUR CULTURE IS A
CORRUPT, TYRANNICAL PATEY.
RUN FOR THE ADD VAN TAPPING
OF MEN.
A PATHOLOGICAL WAY OF
LOOKING AT THE WORLD BUT A
VERY COMMON ONE.
AND IF THAT DESCRIPTION IS
ACCEPTED.
IT MEANS THAT MASCULINE
ENERGY SO, TO SPEAK, WHETHER
IT'S MANIFESTED BY WOMEN OR
BY MEN, MASCULINE ENERGY
DOES NOTHING BUT PROP UP THE
TYRANNY OF THE PARISHY.
AND SHOULD NOT BE FOSTERED
OF THE ONLY PEOPLE WHO THINK
THAT WAY IS WOMEN WHOSE
RELATIONSHIPS WITH MEN HAVE
BEEN EXTRAORDINARILY DAMAGED
OR MEN WHO HAVE NO IDEA WHO
THEY ARE OR WHO ARE TRYING
TO SHIRK RESPONSIBILITY.
THE IDEA THAT MASCULINITY IN
ITS ESSENCE IS SOMEHOW TOXIC
IS AN ABSOLUTELY DREADFUL